Let's do it
"I'll take that as a yes". "What?" "The ring"
The world remains in mourning after the death of Superman violence acts of war and terrorism are all on the rise
I had a dream
It was the end of the world
An invasion
I think it's something more; something darker
We're asking people we don't know to risk their lives
A strong man is strongest alone. You ever heard that. That's not a saying, that's the opposite of what the saying is
Divided, we are not enough
The world needs Superman
I made him a promise
This is why I brought you together
Ride ain't over yet.  My man
Yeah
Oh
Awesome, That's the bat signal. shh Oh, that's your oh, sorry. It's your signal that means we have to go now
Yeah. That's what that means
That's so cool
Hey everybody new Justice League trailer. Superman is back
and there is a new round of Justice League ticket giveaways too - all you have to do to enter is just be a
Subscriber and leave a comment on this video. If you didn't spot it they also released an alternate version of this with some slightly different
Footage so because I don't want to do a completely separate trailer video for that here it is
Maybe you need us
How do you know you're team is strong enough
A strong man is strongest alone. You ever heard that? Thats not a saying . That's the opposite of what the saying is
This is the only way
The five of us
United
So I love the way they opened this with the reveal that
Superman is back until he is not when she wakes up in bed. I'll take that as a yes.
Remember he was going to ask her to marry him at the end of Batman VS.
Superman so Martha gave her the ring
And it hasn't been as long as it seems like I know it's been a while since Batman vs Superman came out
But I think it's only been about six months in the movie, maybe less than a year
But they want all this stuff to devolve into crazy town
Darkseid apocalypse before he comes back. That's why the Justice League has to assemble together
Why they say you know we can't do this alone
I love Aquaman saying too strong men
Stand alone and Batman's like no that's not even close to what the saying is, it's the opposite of that
The color tones are great
You can tell that they polished the CGI a lot too so Zack Snyder is always really good with color
And they do this thing with the songs too, so they use a completely different sound track, but they open it with the Man of Steel
Soundtrack at the beginning when he's standing in that field
They kind of did that with the last trailer where they remix the song just a little bit to make it a little more hardcore
This one is just straight-up Man of Steel at the beginning
Just heralding his return
But the interesting thing that they do at the beginning here is that they show Steppenwolf coming for what looks like
Amazon's in this big field here
And this is where this giant battle scene has been taking place and all the trailers that we've seen so far
But then you get the close-up shot of what looks like a Roman soldier
So it actually seems like because this is the Amazons either
They're on Themiskyra when this happens or they're somewhere on the mainland
And this is taking place in the distant past like Batman tells
Wonder Woman about his dream and everybody sort of has this vision of the
Apocalypse so the vision that he's talking about is probably the one from Batman V Superman the nightmare sequence
But because the three mother boxes were left on earth
Thousands of years ago. This is probably when that event happened like they talk about the Age of Heroes coming again
And Wonder Woman's like I never thought that it would come again
This is probably what she's talking about this older age of Heroes most of you probably picked up on this, too
This is a shot of one of those ancient
Roman soldiers or someone else being turned into a para demon they actually did a version of that during the Justice League war movie
Which is sort of an origin story for the new 52 Justice League where darkside invades and just starts converting a bunch of Earth's people into
parademons
It's much more efficient that way like you don't have to bring that big of a force because as you start
Defeating people like on Game of Thrones the army of the Dead grows exponentially as you kill more people
But you actually do get a better look at Steppenwolf as Wonder Woman's going up against him when they're doing that sequence where they all
Try to go up against him by themselves and get their asses kicked
The real minor change that they made to his backstory for the movie is that he is now
Darkseid's nephew not the other way around way back in the Jack Kirby comics, he was the uncle, Darkseid was the nephew
This is a much better shot of Batman's flying fox
It's just hard to tell the scale because they haven't opened the door to walk out the back yet
But it's huge
He has his Batmobile inside here
And then obviously you see Steppenwolf's giant structure that he starts constructing the minute he hits earth
So then you get to the part of the trailer where they actually start working together
And it starts getting more fun Aquaman gets picked up by cyborg mid-air and thrown
The cool thing about this is that some of these characters are so powerful that you could actually do that you could throw
Aquaman like a football and you wouldn't hurt him that much
Which is why they get to have a little bit more fun like imagine a version of the fastball special where?
Superman throws Wonder Woman at someone else with her sword the reason why you don't see them doing stuff like that is because both of
Them on their own are so powerful that it'd be incredibly redundant
It was kind of hard to tell from the earlier trailers, but now with this extra footage you get more context
So there are a bunch of locations that they visit and try to take down in the movie
So like this is happening in a slightly different place then this giant dome that the flying fox is approaching
So the idea is is that this is happening all over the earth like you see Aquaman getting his ass kicked in
Atlantis when they come for that mother box
So the whole idea here is that Darkseid is tasked
Steppenwolf with getting the three mother boxes and they confirm that the third one the human mother box is actually part of cyborg now
I know there was a little bit of confusion as to the last trailer
But there was some language and some of the marketing where it was
Basically like yeah part of the thing that they want is now part of one of the people that is in the Justice League
So it's a bit like Vision and the Mind Gem
You can only get it by completely
Dismantling this other person so as is a lot of narratives and big movies like this
You know typically the villain comes right up to the brink of achieving his goal
Or he achieves it and then something happens like Superman comes back and they defeat him
But I think that's kind of the idea. That they need to unite everybody including Superman
And they can't defeat him until they do so that's why Steppenwolf is so over confident because he's like you don't have any
Kryptonians you don't have any Lanterns
So there's nothing you can do to stop me. Like even though all of them together as you see them in the trailer here
Before Superman comes back are really badass
There's nothing that they can do
But let me know in the comments, how bad do you think that it's going to get for them
before Superman comes back
They all rally and finally take him down
The only thing that I think that they've changed about the ending like there's been a lot of reports about how they made some edits
To the way the film ends I think that they've minimized
Darkseid a little bit because I think the idea was is that day to beat Steppenwolf
But Darkseid still needs the mother boxes so he shows up and says you're all
Royally screwed now and that sort of opens the door for Green Lantern
And more people to show up during the second Justice League movie
But because they pulled back a little bit on the world-building in the DCEU
I think we'll still see some Darkseid related stuff happening
But they'll still leave that up in the air in case they want to change anything before they make that next movie
And if you're wondering there will be another Justice League movie
But they have so many other
Spin-off movies like the next Wonder Woman movie the Aquaman movie whatever the next Man of Steel movie is gonna
Look like the Batman franchise the flashpoint movie that they want to focus on those first before they do another Justice League team-up
Favorite line from the trailer aside from all the Superman stuff at the beginning is the fact that the flash is just so
Excited at the sight of Batman signal and sort of calls him out as Batman without
Realizing that Wonder Woman already knows that Bruce Wayne is Batman so she's like yeah, haha
Yeah, I know. I know who he is I know he's the Batman. Yeah. We have to go. But let me know
What's your favorite part of this? What do you think about the Superman twist? Like oh
He's back. Until he's not. He's really just a hallucination at this point, but clearly he's coming back
They keep having visions of apocalypse
Maybe Lois at the same time will keep having visions of Superman and that's how we'll see earlier in the film
But if you're wondering how Superman can't come back solar radiation actually does
Penetrate down into the earth just at a much slower rate than if he were just sitting outside on the pavement
But we'll see how he actually winds up showing up in the movie
I'm just expecting them to turn around and for him to be there like after Lois has a couple more
Hallucinations like wow I keep having visions of him, but not exactly like it is in Lois's visions
But if you guys didn't know there's gonna be a new Star Wars trailer tomorrow night
So I'll post that video after it drops. I'll also be posting some new Rick and Morty
There'll be some Game of Thrones later tonight, too, so whole bunch of stuff happening
Congratulations to Jorge De Ocampo
You're the latest ticket giveaway winner please private message me on the back end of my channel so I can get your contact details
You can click here for brand new Flash, and you can click here for a brand new Thor and infinity war
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight